alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet
comenzó este lunes una visita en china
se trata de la primera vez en casi dos
décadas que una autoridad de los
derechos humanos de la onu visita el
país asiático según su oficina bachelet
se reunirá con varios altos cargos del
gobierno chino así como como
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
representantes académicos
empresariales además de una presentación
para los estudiantes de la universidad
de canto
la visita de bachelet criticada por el
gobierno de los eeuu coincide con la
visita del presidente de los eeuu en
japón durante la rueda de prensa
efectuada hoy en tokio vaivén aseguró
que no descartó utilizar sus fuerzas
militares si china decide invadir taiwán
por su parte el primer ministro de japón
fungicida aseguró que trabajarán en
cooperación ambos países a fin de
enfrentar las dificultades económicas
garantizar el suministro de comida y
garantizar la paz también afirmó que
cuenta con el apoyo de los eeuu para
asegurar su puesto permanente en el
consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas